il ya un proverbe persan donc c'est
l'iran qui dit ne partageait pas en
ajoutant des doutes au doute de là
manuel valls et londres que l'on peut
rassurer stabiliser alors qu'elle a
quelque chose qui relève bon de la
manoeuvre que de vouloir au sol oui vous
le repoussez françois hollande dehors au
motif qu'il ya eu un livre qui
effectivement pas le meilleur livre
auquel et contribuer de françois
hollande
lorsque vous garder un secret si vous le
garder c'est votre esclave
si vous le dévoiler c'est vous qui est
indemne et l'esclave ce qui n'est pas à
la hauteur
c'est le spectacle sans précédent d'un
premier ministre qui a honte du
président qu'il l'a nommé si j'étais
choisi
je confierais matignon à françois bas et
le roi baroin et je fais parfois bayrou
petit lapsus c'est toujours amusant j'ai
dit baroin
le débat qui tenteraient de se dérouler
et les attaques par exemple à l'égard de
françois bayrou n'aurait au spa me
semble-t-il le débat barbero et
manifestons un problème personnel avec
nicolas sarkozy il a insulté à travers
lui il a insulté tous ceux qui
soutiennent nicolas sarkozy quand on a
quelqu'un qui a été trois fois pré
candidats présents ce république
trois fois il a échoué premier tour il
récupère une udf qui avait 100 députés
il y en a plus un seul et toutes les
personnalités qui sait allier ça c'est
mal tourné mais c'est le choix d'un
juppé car vous soutenez alain juppé
j'entends jean fin ça vous a pas échappé
qui est attaqué par les sarkozystes en
raison du soutien de françois bayrou
nous refusons le centre girouette qui
est avec nous lundi pour gagner la ville
de pau et qui est le mardi avec françois
hollande pour concourir au tour du
socialisme à la tête du pays
pour gagner il faut que des gens
capables d pour nous avant maintenant
votre prono
donc il faut qu'il vienne mais alain
juppé n'est pas un dealer pour moi qui
veut une rupture très franche
avec le quinquennat socialiste qu'on
vient de vivre alain juppé a deux atouts
maîtres est une femme politique de
premier plan
elle préside la première région
française 12 millions d'habitants donc
effectivement tout le monde attendait un
peu son choix vers c est là le droit on
est quand même libre je suis pas faire
de procès à qui que ce soit parce qu'il
fut un choix les prix un sondage à
paraître demain un sondage ifop très
sérieux pour psychologies magazine sur
la gentillesse la question c'est quel
candidat est le plus gentil et la
réponse c'est vous est ce que vous vous
en bouche un coin
je ne suis pas est-ce que vous avez un
mot gentil pour nicolas sarkozy qui est
le dernier de ce classement
alain juppé en visite ce matin
argenteuil
après avoir dévoilé hier une affiche de
campagne plutôt austère le community
manager du compte de campagne de nicolas
sarkozy est allé de son petit message il
n'a pas hésité à faire le parallèle
entre cette affiche et un faire part de
décès depuis là il a retiré son tweet
c'est quand même plus polis